has a fear of fire uh-huh but dragons
breathe fire not me
did you know about the amazing voice
cast behind Netflix's My Father's Dragon
you're gonna wanna hear about this are
we ready this is recording the movie
yeah okay number one who doesn't love
Gayton Matarazzo we all know and love
him as Dustin from stranger things and
now we know and love him in his Dragon
form as Boris in My Father's Dragon I'm
so lucky I could explode the hook feels
so I can thank you Gayton clearly became
Pals with his co-star Jacob Tremblay
while the pair were recording together
they even attended onset school together
though according to Jacob Gayton spent a
lot more time watching Star Wars videos
than he did studying he watched Star
Wars videos the whole time
Stars they're just like us it's clear
that Gayton had an amazing time playing
Boris especially doing all those sound
effects it's a work in progress
it's like the worst part about it but
it's pretty fun to do and since Gayton
is a Broadway trained actor and singer
it's really no surprise that he's
killing it at voice acting yeah that's
probably better number two Jacob
Tremblay had quite an interesting time
making this movie wait
Jacob is only 16 years old and he's
already racked up lots of awards
accolades and even a decade-long career
so it's no wonder that he plays Elmer
alvatore the protagonist of my father's
dragon so well are you for real you he's
taken on plenty of other voice acting
roles in the past playing the titular
roles in Luca every day Mina Alberto are
gonna ride someplace new and Pete the
Cat his role in My Father's Dragon is
definitely one he's never going to
forget though why you ask it's
um nice well because in the time between
recording for the movie and when the
movie actually came out his voice
changed my father's dragon was filming
pre-pandemic and that put things on hold
meaning that the movie wasn't released
until years later this gave Jacob just
enough time to grow up a little in the
interim it's safe to say that this role
will stick with the actor for that
reason because he clearly made a friend
on set it was a wonderful experience
because getting such an amazing actor
and we just had so much fun together
number three Leighton meester's voice is
featured in My Father's Dragon yes
that's Blair Waldorf herself since
playing the iconic ambitious fashionista
Blair Waldorf on Gossip Girl Leighton
has played her fair share pair of movie
roles but it's safe to say this role is
quite a departure for her she plays
Sasha a super cute tiger twin we'd
recognize that voice anywhere what's
this thing it looks sweet and cute
number four Leighton also got to work
with her hubby Adam Brody on this
project yes just like his wife Adam
Rhody was also a fan favorite on an
early Arts teen drama he played Seth
Cohen on the OC and to think that man is
a dentist Adam's role as Bob in My
Father's Dragon wasn't his first time in
the recording booth either he played
Woody on the TV series Good Vibes
picking board isn't like picking a
girlfriend you have to be choosy and
while you definitely recognize Leighton
meester's voice Bob sounds pretty much
nothing like Adam uh you know the kind
that keeps beards out of soup number
five Whoopi Goldberg plays The Cat In My
Father's Dragon just let me know when
you're ready and then I'll answer any
questions you have While most of us know
what be best for her acting roles and
these days as a co-host on The View she
has racked up quite a few voice acting
credits over the course of her long
career from luck to Toy Story 3 Whoopi
is an expert in providing the voice for
some favorite animated characters I'm
talking cat no no she likes making
movies that her grandkids can watch she
also loves working on projects where she
doesn't have to go through hair and
makeup to go to work and we can all
definitely relate to that keep taking
those roles Whoopi I have a cat I'm very
happy number six Yara Shahidi plays Cali
you took our customer she was about to
put that coin in my hat blackish and
grown-ish fans know y'all as Zoe Johnson
but just because she's best known for
being in front of the camera that
doesn't mean that she hasn't done a
little voice acting before she's
actually had quite a few animated roles
such as DreamWorks troll Hunters Tales
of Arcadia smallfoot do you have
something better integrity and Netflix
is fearless to name a few on this movie
Yara was joined by someone she's worked
with before any guesses who number 7.
Spence more II has also appeared on
gronish plus he's had a ton of other
credits since his first ever TV
appearance on Criminal Minds back in
2016. he's had roles in series like 13
Reasons Why and we are who we are as for
my father's dragon he plays George the
tiger who is Sasha AKA Leighton
meester's twin no way you're messing
with me number eight Judy Greer is
taking a totally different form in this
movie okay Judy is more than just the
ultimate best friend in some of our
favorite flicks like the wedding planner
and 13 Going On 30. she's also appeared
in hits like Arrested Development the
Halloween franchise and most recently
the Hulu series reboot in terms of voice
acting she's had recurring roles on
Archer Family Guy and American Dad to
name a few so it's clear that Ms Greer
has a truly coveted voice as for my
father's dragon she plays soda who is
probably the cutest whale we've ever
seen wanna see why I'm
number nine if you don't know Charlene
Yi you probably just don't realize you
know her her voice acting has been
featured in tons of animated series like
Steven Universe first thing I did was
get crowned together with a bunch of
other rubies summer camp Island and we
bear bears
listen when she's not voice acting you
can see her acting in plenty of TV
series and movies but she had enough
free time to play Magda In My Father's
Dragon that's the best I can do number
10 Rita Moreno's character Mrs McLaren
makes quite a splash as far as we and
probably most of Hollywood are concerned
if you get the opportunity to cast her
in your project you take it well it's
clear the creators behind my father's
dragon are fully in agreement with this
since Rita Moreno plays Mrs McLaren in
the movie sorry but you can't trust
anyone these days nothing personal
knowing her icon status it's really no
surprise that she's made Mrs McLaren
into a fan favorite if you've ever seen
West Side Story you know that Moreno has
a legendary voice girls here are free to
have fun she is in America now number 11
Ian McShane is known for playing some
rather intimidating characters in My
Father's Dragon he plays seiwa who just
so happens to be a pretty intimidating
gorilla so we think this is a very
fitting role for him quiet down now
there is no need to be afraid and Ian
McShane is no newbie to voice acting
either nor is he a newbie to voicing
some bad guy animals you may recognize
his voice as Tai Lung from Kung Fu Panda
he was also Gordon in SpongeBob
SquarePants yes we're serious number 12.
Alan [ __ ] has played a ton of roles
in his life but it's safe to say that
he's never played an alligator who has
really Alan [ __ ] plays Cornelius and
he has pretty much the perfect voice for
it though we do wish this alligator sang
just a little name is Cornelius and I
agree
number 13. Chris O'Dowd plays Quan
listen to you I trusted you who Chris
himself describes as a baboon with a lot
of anger issues if you don't know Chris
O'Dowd he's an actor and comedian known
for hits like Bridesmaids and the it
crowd Chris has done his fair share of
voice acting before voicing characters
in Family Guy Monsters vs Aliens and The
Simpsons to name a few for the last time
we can't just turn down jobs because
it's our anniversary even so it's pretty
clear that he loved working on my
father's dragon he even read the book to
his kids what do you think of this
amazing voice cast who was your favorite
tell us about it in the comments and if
you want to see more videos just like
this one be sure to like And subscribe
to the things